et ce week end là vont en scène vous
présente les voix ont le blues du rock
un concert de fin d'année des adhérents
de l'atelier concert de l'association
une dizaine de chanteurs viendront à
jouer sur scène ça se passera samedi 12
juin à 20 heures à l'espace alphonse
daudet est de coignières le thème de ces
dames cette année vous l'aurez compris
c'est le blues et le rock dans les
classiques on attend le second rang on a
tiré aux tuiles ira donc on essaye
vraiment varié français et anglais voilà
on a du tuning c'est vraiment un
maillage on est sur un univers blues
puis rock et on va s'amuser un petit peu
a passé voilà faire un passage entre le
12 et le rock et réservations à faire
via le site elle avoue en scène